[Music]
hello and
for I'm M I'm 37 years old and I'm
Belgian I joined the Commission in
Brussels 10 years ago as an economist
and currently I'm working for the
competition Policy Department uh where
I'm part of the team dealing with state
aid to banks in difficulty so like that
I help to ensure that uh government
support to Banks um does not distort
Fair competition in in the European
market mark this is not my uh first job
in the commission I already switched
once so during my first 5 years at the
commission I worked on the economic and
budgetary surveillance of Italy one of
the largest Euro Zone member
[Music]
states in my daily work uh I get to
handle sometimes quite sensitive cases
that raise um intellectually challenging
questions legal aspects economic aspects
and it's very exciting to tackle those
questions in team and to Think Through
the the policy um tradeoffs and then go
and present our work to the commissioner
in person what I also like is uh the
fact that I get to speak to quite a lot
of stakeholders uh concerning my work
for instance other departments in the
commission but also the national
authorities of member states or other EU
institutions like the European Central
Bank and sometimes that involves
traveling uh for instance three months
ago I uh went to Luxembourg to attend a
hearing at the court of justice and that
was a very interesting experience for me
and then finally um what I also like a
lot is that the commission offers a lot
of um opportunities for training and
development uh both internal and
external for instance in my first job in
the commission I was given the
opportunity to learn Italian and I also
attended a three-week summer school on
Banking and Finance in
[Music]
London one of the things I like the most
about the commission is the internal job
Mobility
in fact working at the commission can
mean a lifetime of different jobs uh the
commission makes policy in so many
domains that there's countless of
interesting positions to move to during
one's career and for instance in my case
um I moved already once and it was a
very good decision in terms of my own
professional development but also
getting to know other policies and new
colleagues of course another thing I
like a lot is the international work
environment with uh colleagues coming
from all corners of Europe for instance
in my team we have 30 people
uh but we have 12 different
nationalities so it's a true reflection
I think of the diversity in Europe and
then finally I think the commission is
quite unique place it's a unique
government Administration and political
organization that's at the center of the
European integration project which um is
a project uh for the greater good of our
continent and its citizens and a project
I very strongly uh believe in personally
and that motivates me day in Day
Out
he